a little cool this morning for the
kiddos so definitely make sure they get
on jackets warm coats as they head out
the door and same for yourself seeing
just a hint of a high cloud out there
but really very clear compared to
yesterday and just to call your
attention again to these evenings with
clear skies now that gives us an
opportunity to see a beautiful setup in
the southwest sky after sunset the moon
which is building back a little bit more
each night set up with jupiter tonight
in the southwest sky so it's been venus
mercury saturn now tonight with jupiter
again about 40 minutes after the sun
goes down look off to the southwest
should be a beautiful sight we'll keep
clear skies today into this evening
we've got a lot of 30s around town we're
not freezing really except at red rock
and nellis at 31 but everybody else has
maintained some pretty good temperatures
but i want to show you what's going on
in the upper midwest and the northern
plains we're looking at wind chills
minus 32 in fargo this morning with
blowing blizzard conditions minus 31 in
duluth and this is right here this time
is just the minutes that it would take
before hypothermia sets in if you're
exposed to these elements outdoors but
wow the wind chills all the way down to
des moines over to chicago even st louis
bitterly cold this morning and these are
all wind chill and blizzard warnings all
through the northern plains the midwest
and even down into the mid-south it is
so cold now the winds will subside a
little bit by midday into the afternoon
but it will be followed by some pretty
good snow showers those are already
starting to take shape you can see in
minnesota and wisconsin eventually some
more snow will make its way back to the
east coast again by the end of the week
for us we're seeing the clouds really
retreat lift to the north with another
system into the pacific northwest we'll
stay dry we've got good sunshine coming
today we may see a wispy cloud here or
there but overall good sunshine and
warmer so we're on this nice warming
trend as high pressure rebuilds over the
desert that'll keep us dry and
temperatures into the 60s 60 today 62
tomorrow the mornings will get a little
bit milder as the afternoons warm up mid
60s for friday slightly cooler for the
weekend but still just a little bit
above the norm of 57 and then next week
a few clouds around but so far no rain
in the forecast with those clouds